in this video we'll talk about
electroencephalogram
or eeg
this is a non-invasive method to record
the macroscopic electrical activity by
placing electrodes on the scalp
eeg recordings represent the activity of
the surface layer in the brain
now
electroencephalogram is basically the
output of the eeg machine and these
graphs represent the electrical activity
coming from the brain
during this diagnostic test a small
sensor is placed all across the scalp
to record the electrical activity coming
underneath the skull and this is
generally non-invasive and painless
these signals are recorded by a machine
and the doctor can interpret the meaning
of these signal in this video we'll try
to understand what does this signal mean
how this test is performed and what is
the biological and physical basis behind
this test
so let's talk about where are these
electrode placed actually these
electrodes are placed using a
conventional system of 10 20 rule
and in a moment it would be clear what
is this convention
but let me tell you these are broadly
placed on the scalp
and the neurons which are active just
underneath the scalp that means in the
cortical layer their activity can be
recorded using
eeg
now the
waveform that is coming out of a
encephalogram actually represent or
reflects the electrical activity of
cortical neurons
the signal intensity is very small
and
these uh
particular fluctuations are in order of
microvolts that means it's very small
now it detects population level of
neuronal activity
it does not depict one single neurons
activity now let's try to understand the
placement of electrodes in bit more
details so this is the skull and we are
looking at the skull from a top view
here let's try to understand some
landmarks and this is how
a particular technician will put the
electrodes on the scalp
so
the particular end which is close to the
nose is known as nasion
so first
the nasion electrode is placed it's kind
of like a landmark
then the ionian electrode is placed
which is at the back of the scalp
and then
the pre
auricular points are detected which are
close to our ears and those electrodes
are placed and with respect to these
landmarks other electrodes are placed in
a specific
fashion
for example from the nasian electrode
the first
line that can connect the ionian and
nasian is known as the midline
the next electrode to be placed is
something arbitrary 10 units apart from
the nasian electrode
but once this particular electrode is
placed the next electrode is to be
placed 20 units or 20 percent distance
with respect to the uh previous one and
this is known as the 1020 rule
there are several rules of nomenclature
which would be important to understand
the data for example
you must be seeing these kind of
notations in the eeg recordings like fz
cz or pz
so p stands for parietal c stands for
central and if stands for frontal so all
these notation tells us where where
these electrodes are placed in the brain
and where does the activity is recorded
so it's kind of like a geography on the
brain
now t stands for temporal
here when we see t8 or c4 we have to
understand these recordings are taken
from the right half of the scalp whereas
if we see odd numbers like c3 or t9 we
have to understand these are recordings
coming from the left half of the brain
so these conventions are really
important to understand the traces now
if we look at a sample trace we can
clearly understand what does these
stress mean for example if p1 clearly
indicates that it is from
you guessed it correct from the frontal
part and it's from the left hemisphere
fp2 is from the frontal part but it is
from the right hemisphere
similarly c3 and c4 you can completely
understand t3 and t4 are coming from
temporal rope
so this is how the nomenclature is set
up
now let's try to understand exactly how
eeg works
so this is a portion of the scalp we can
look at the electrode here
and underneath the electrode there is
scalp and underneath the scalp there
would be meninges and beneath that there
will be the cortical layer where we can
see the neurons are there here the red
neurons are synapsed with these blue
neurons or the axonal terminals of these
blue neurons if we zoom into this axonal
terminal we can see that there are
neurotransmission going on
so in this particular excitatory synapse
whenever there is
electrical activity there would be
cation influx inside of these red
neurons or the dendrites of these red
neurons
so there would be net buildup of
positive charge inside the neuron but at
the same time there would be depletion
of the positive charge in the outside of
the neuron or the extracellular site of
the neuron and there would be a
development of negative charge on the
outer side and these kind of delta
changing charge is detected by the
electroencephalogram
so now we can understand when the charge
is now more negative
there would be a downward deflection in
the voltage that is detected by a eeg
trace
and this is recorded over time so what
we see as a trace is a recording of
voltage fluctuation over time and it can
be order of several minutes to several
hours
now let us try to understand how exactly
the eeg data is represented
the easy data is actually understood in
context of
a differential gating parameter
so here there are two inputs
in these two inputs are feed into this
eeg machine
and that would give or give rise to an
output but since it's a differential
amplifier kind of
machinery
we can see only the differences are
taken as an output if we see this input
1 and input 2 we can see the point of
difference here as a peak and this
differences is
the thing that would be
taken as an output
so now if we look at a particular
electroencephalograms
trace we can see
these kind of traces are known as
bipolar montage that means the
differences between two electro
electrodes are pointed out for example
fp1 and f3 means the differences between
these electrical activities in these two
sites
already if we look at these particular
recordings we can see
there are differences like the c3 and p3
the electrical activities are not so
much different that's why the
fluctuations are less
now in terms of fp1 and fp f3 we can see
the differences are quite uh stark and
that's why there are a lot of
fluctuations in the traces there are
many other ways of representing the
electroencephalogram data but in this
video we are not going to focus on that
and complicate things
okay let's talk about the
important aspect of eeg
eeg recordings
depicts the population level activity
that means it's kind of tell us
overall activity of a brain area it does
not point out how a single neuron
behaves
if we want to understand how a single
neuron behave we have to do
intracellular recording using specific
electrodes
and if you want to learn more about
intracellular recordings you can click
on the video in the i button
but overall easy recordings give us an
idea about the population level
macroscopic activity now there are
several signatures in the eeg waveforms
such as delta theta alpha beta and all
of these thing has different frequencies
for example delta has a frequency range
of one to four hertz whereas gamma has a
frequency of more than 35 hertz and all
of these signature has their own meaning
some signatures are predominant when the
individual is awake and some signatures
are predominant when the individual is
asleep
so these kind of signatures means a lot
in terms of brain activity
a trend doctor can understand what does
these signatures actually mean in terms
of a clinical point of view
now electroencephalogram could be a very
good diagnostic tool to detect epilepsy
especially if we look at a normal
individual the eeg traces would look
like this but once an individual is
undergoing a seizure or epileptic
seizure
the electroencephalogram would
completely change and a huge amount of
activity would be visualized using this
kind of method
now electroencephalogram can also be
used to diagnose sleep related disorder
in different phases of sleep there are
different electroencephalogram signals
so one can try to match these
electroencephalogram signals to
determine what changes happened in sleep
quality and
especially it is important for people
who are insomniac and suffering from
other kind of sleep
disabilities
it can also be useful for diagnosis of
depression
anxiety related behaviors and many other
things
but there are certain disadvantages
associated with these method so let's
review that
so the advantages are plenty for example
it's good for monitoring population
level neural activity in behaving humans
also it is non-invasive in nature so
it's pretty easy to do
but there are certain disadvantages like
poor resolution
it cannot tell the activity at a single
neuron resolution it can only talk about
a population level of activity it can
only tell us that whether our brain area
is active inactive and how much that
activity is
so it's a ballpark estimate not absolute
one
it just gives us an overview of activity
but no intricate details are provided
from the electroencephalogram recordings
so i hope this video was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up
get notes and more flashcards in my
facebook page link is in the description
don't forget to follow that
also you can support my channel by
clicking on this super like option your
small contribution means a lot for me
anyway if you need more dynamic flash
cards you can definitely visit my
facebook page you can download
animations that would help in your
presentation or understanding
my courses are also present in an
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform using a code ap ap10
you can get a 10 discount see you in
next video